whatever this is not happening will
stories from all right everyone buckle
up we're gonna do this one by the number
drops jump in the back of my head
catches on fire whoo all my friends
they're all doing drugs except me
because I'm the host of crisis right
okay well I guess that settles said I
was peed on I think about that man in
his balls every single day in my life
whoo mutilated my generals
you know why they say don't shoot the
messenger because they always shoot the
messenger shouldn't because against but
would never kill somebody this
is not so he decided to rob the told you
two things one you're gonna get AIDS
I'll just be out here waiting for that
aids dick and - you're definitely
getting hit man how's about you
turn in the trunk of a car they had my
phone tap the other helicopter came over
my hose hurry up someone's trying to go
on stage and be them goddamn joke I'm a
black comic where my people a little bit
nice to know before we got on stage I
get now that I have one arm a little
but that still pretty good there's no
tip there was no fingering it was just
straight on Drive
now that's it does see you later you're
welcome
you